in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Bobby are here hey guys how are you
hey Dave hey Chris
welcome welcome where you guys from
we're from Macomb Michigan which is near
Detroit Detroit okay welcome to
Nashville you and you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes and how much have
you guys paid off we've paid off a
hundred and eighty five thousand dollars
in 14 months that's ridiculous
making what kind of money 145 okay so
did you sell something big we did we
sold our rental property okay and what
did it sell for it sold for about 130
well we were able to net okay and so you
had 55,000 more you had to cashflow we
actually had about 80 70 or 80 to cash
flow the rental also filled our baby
step three for the emergency fund oh
okay alright so included in that I
gotcha all right I see very cool so
you've been on fire mm-hmm so tell me
the story what kind of debt was this a
part of it was the rental property and
what else um mostly student that student
loan debt
mostly his okay so what's your degree in
I've a degree in chemical engineering oh
that's good news all right so thus part
of this income then that's right very
cool and what do you do for a living
Bobby I'm a nurse oh very cool good -
great great career tracks then excellent
good and so what did you do with the
degree David what do you do I'm an
engineer for a utility company and
natural gas engineer ah very cool so
both have you right in your fields
access well done well done so tell me
the story what happened 14 months ago
that you go through this drastic
metamorphosis we were living in Wyoming
and we needed to buy a new car and I
thought I knew what I was doing with
finances I mean I was I had $100,000 in
student loan debt so I was like yeah I
know what I'm doing and and a co-worker
suggested that I read the Total Money
Makeover and I was like Dave Ramsey he
doesn't know what he's talking about
like I got this figured out and when I
got to the part where you talk about
don't buy a new car the warranties not
worth it
I was like man this guy just blew my
mind he changed my life so I got on
board started talking to Bobby about it
and from there we're like yeah let's
let's change our lives so you go from
Wyoming to we moved back to Michigan
back it's a process - okay all right for
jobs or I'd be back with family okay so
yeah we want to start a family and we
need to be close to the close to the
ranch yeah that's good
needs a baby sitting that's good you get
that free babysitting yeah that's that's
a budgeting thinking right there
yep very cool so so you move and you put
the house up for the rental up for sale
and you move into Detroit and what
happened what did you guys do to get out
of debt then you both read the book
that's right we also took FPU Oh
so one of the agreements that we had was
before we buy a new house in Michigan we
needed to go through FPU together so we
could kind of be on the same page and so
we had like a little tiny apartment and
we're just going on our budget and
nickel and diamond here and there
wherever we can to to save money scrap
it together and get out of debt as soon
as possible and now you're free making
one hundred and forty five thousand
dollars a year how's that feels great
it's awesome yeah what was the hardest
thing you did in the last 14 months just
changing our lifestyle you know not
being able to do everything that we
wanted to do travel and go to events and
stuff like that we didn't really have a
lot of date nights you know no cable
stuff like that yeah so so Bobby he
comes in with this idea of this book and
completely transforms from buying a new
car to not buying a car at all and he's
gonna go beans and rice on you what did
you say I was hesitant at first but I
mean I thought we were always gonna be
in debt and then the thought of us not
being in debt
made me excited so we just went ahead
and did it
so you really paid a tough price I mean
you guys have lived on nothing I mean if
you had friends with you bought from
Wyoming they'd have been making fun of
you wouldn't they a couple people made
fun of us yeah I bet so was it worth it
absolutely yeah how's it feel right now
I mean I mean this is real now being
here this is what I was like all right
we got to go to Nashville yup exactly I
do our scream and then I'll feel
for us now that's very cool yeah so when
people ask you how did you do that what
do you tell them the secret to getting
out of that is stick with the budget
stay focused on the end goal you know
you're gonna have to sacrifice things
but in the end it's gonna be all worth
it yeah very cool
so Chris I mean sitting here talking
about retiring inspired they're making
145,000 payment in the world I think
their retirement plan might be okay what
do you think I think their dreams are
gonna come to fruition I mean they paid
the price like they said by renting and
staying focused and they're gonna be
able to reap the rewards later Dave it's
amazing I'm very proud of you too thanks
for congratulations guys hey we're gonna
give you a you're our first debt free
scream since the retire inspired book
came out and so we're gonna sign you up
for the the pre-sale with all the
special the whole goodies all the $70
worth of stuff so that will take care of
you and just to just to celebrate with
you here and you get Chris's book in the
process of being here on this very
special day while we're doing something
cool okay that's great thank you so much
congratulations guys all right David it
Bobby what I was gonna say hey could I
just give a quick shout out to the
people that are going through FPU right
now our Kensington church you can yep we
believe any guys if it's starting to get
difficult for you don't give up there
were times when Bobby and I were just
sitting there and we're like this isn't
worth it let's just start blowing cash
and now we're free and we don't have to
worry about anymore so don't give up I
believe in you guys Wow well done sir
good all right David and Bobby from
Detroit Michigan I love it
congratulations a hundred and eighty
five thousand dollars paid off in 14
months including on top of that baby
step three coming out of the sale of a
rental properties part of that one
hundred and forty five thousand dollar
income count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
congratulations you two very very very
well done man that's awesome
you